[Music]
so my name is laurence friedman
i was professor of war studies at king's
college london
until 2014 i'm being emeritus
professor of war studies since then um
but i still write and research on
all aspects of armed conflict
i was a member of the iraq inquiry but i
also
write more generally on strategic issues
broadly defined how people
do strategy as well as big geopolitical
questions
and would you be able to explain what
how the iraq inquiry came about or what
role you played in it
uh well the iraq inquiry came about
because
the prime minister of the day gordon
brown
had been persuaded that his backbenchers
were
unhappy with what had happened with iraq
and wanted to understand it better
he set it up as a lessons learned
inquiry my role
was that i was appointed to be a member
of the panel so i only knew about it
as a thing to do about a few days before
it was announced
um but then there were five of us sadly
one died martin gilbert and
so we held the hearing through the
questioning of witnesses
oversaw the writing of the report
contributed to the report
took responsibility for the judgment in
the report which came out in
uh 2016. what
was the outcome of these well the main
job of the report
was to um
i think to to to provide a full account
a reliable account of what had actually
happened
which meant going into considerable
detail on that basis
uh the inquiry obviously had to form
judgment on responsibility
which i suppose the most important
judgment was
that the
prime minister blair had
gone to war before diplomacy had been
exhausted
it wasn't a last resort um and
secondly the preparations for the
conflict had been very poor
and therefore the aftermath was pretty
awful
and that could have been foreseen
possibly
at least mitigated and do you think it's
important that nations have this
process of inquiry into wars well
you don't i mean a lot of conflict goes
on
um and people are asked hopefully asking
questions and challenging
all the way through i think when
something
like iraq where people felt they'd been
misled
um it's important to have
uh a reckoning of some sort um so i
think it is a it was a healthy
thing to do i wouldn't particularly
advocate it for every conflict
it's not a cheap thing to do it takes a
lot of time
and you may end up just rediscovering
what you already knew
but in this case i think it was
important that people had a full
description a really full description
from which they could necessarily form
their own judgments about what happened
uh and why it had happened so in that
sense i think it was useful
uh a good thing to do um but you know
these these things should only be
undertaken for
special cases rather than just as a
matter of course
and so would you say it was more about
the general public's
feelings or the access to knowledge
about the war rather than
the government learning from lessons
well i think the word i mean it's a fair
point
and i think we did
make recommendations and draw some
lessons
about can you influence an american
administration
uh how do you prepare uh for
the aftermath of a conflict um
some issues to do with military planning
and logistics they're also doing the
things it would be nice to think the
government might learn from and i know
some bits of government have been trying
to learn from but i think
you know the reason for the inquiry was
that
um it was premised on the assumption
that there were
weapons of mass destruction in iraq
which were never found and
certainly didn't exist and secondly
um that it dragged on a long time
and was very painful not least for the
iraqis and
the blood of our own service people were
killed
um and so i think there was a feeling
that something had gone
wrong in terms of both what had been
promised and unintended consequences
so in that sense uh it was addressing
public concern
would you be able to go into a little
bit more detail about how you said that
some parts of government are trying to
learn from the lessons in what ways is
that happening well the ministry of
defense has produced a
sort of little little booklet about
things that you need to take into
account with many any military operation
um and i think one of the conclusions we
were trying to push
was that if you were in government
whether in the military or a civil
servant and you were bothered
um then you really should challenge and
you should feel able to challenge
what was going on you know if everybody
believes something that turns out to be
completely wrong and there was a bit of
that in this case
uh then the challenge may be limited but
in some areas people were worried
had concerns uh and didn't quite know
how to
express them and i you know be good to
think the
the if we ever were doing something like
this again
which i'm not sure we will but if we
ever did um
that people had concerns they would feel
able to
say uh um
really isn't a very good idea or have
you thought of this or why don't you try
that
um there's limits to how far that can go
in the end somebody's got to take
responsibility
uh and that may involve ignoring
reasonable concerns but at least they
should know that
those concerns are there and that if
they how do decide to ignore them
they're doing so explicitly
and looking to the future you've done
work on how you see
war will progress in the future moving
more to civil wars rather than
international wars what is your theory
of the future
i don't have a theory i mean the the the
the future of war
is as likely as not to look pretty much
like the pastor of war
um in the last few decades
civil wars have become more important
than interstates interstate wars were
always
you know few and far between very nasty
when they occurred
but civil wars are pretty constant
there are some on all the time and some
of them are very bloody indeed
and conventional
sort of conventional wars that people
think about
you know may happen in terms of regular
armies fighting each other
um but a lot of the wars do take place
and militias
firing waters in the vague direction of
other militias
and societies gradually breaking down
with
tragic human consequences so
sadly these wars continue we haven't
really
done very well in finding ways either
through the u.n
or elsewhere um to
stop them when they they died then the
syrian
conflict may subside a bit because
uh one side effectively assad there's
one but
it'll never quite he'll never quite get
control of his country again
i mean there's a proliferation of civil
war but isn't it still international in
nature if we look at the
financing of war or whether yes i mean
it's
um
there's never any truly internal
conflict and even the american civil war
you know had an external important
external dimensions
who you know where do you go to for
support why'd you go to for
finance and weaponry and so on obviously
these make a difference
and then a lot of say the african wars
around say the great lakes region
other countries have just interfered
they've come in on one side rather than
other that may do it in the guise of
peacekeeping
but essentially they're um
they're participants so you can't really
often make a sharp distinction between
interstate and interstate
wars they blur into one another
especially
in these parts of the world where
the political structures are are not
very well defined already and borders
don't always mean very much do you think
the stakes have
risen though do you think nuclear
weaponry is sort of
a major breaking change or is it just
that wars develop in different ways or
do you see
um well nuclear weapons don't affect
civil wars very much but
the existence of nuclear weapons from
1945
the city had a very important dampening
effect
on major war conflict if you think
that if you take a an aggressive step
you could well find yourself in a
complete conflagration that would
demolish your country as well as much
else then you're going to be a little
bit more cautious
than if you think there's costs and
risks but
maybe they're worth taking so i think
what nuclear weapons have done is it
makes it harder to conceive
of major powers going to war or even
nuclear power say india and pakistan go
into war though we've got close to that
in recent times but
other forms of conflict will will carry
on and possibly become more important
simply because um the big wars
are aren't going to happen now so
you may the major powers may try to
pursue their interest through support of
factions in elsewhere rather rather than
take on their opponents directly and
you've talked slightly about the sort of
failure
or that we haven't found a way of
stopping war
do you think uh a sort of global
framework like the un
will still be relevant if we're seeing
civil wars uh
well it can be relevant um it can be
more relevant with civil wars than other
types
a lot of peacekeeping forces have been
sent in but unfortunately
you know they're not disinterested
and in some cases they've made it worse
rather than better um
[Music]
if you produce armies of not
particularly well paid
young men
they don't necessarily behave well in
the countries which they're going
um and not always very well disciplined
so
uh so they're further so firstly yes
there is a
the un can do things can organize
conferences
try to establish uh peaceful settlements
uh try to support them through
peacekeeping in some cases it's done
that quite well which wouldn't be
too negative but there are limits in
what it can do
and probably the limits are feel a bit
more
strong people are more aware of the
limits at the moment than the past was
greater optimism in the past and now
there's certain areas of the world that
you predict will be sort of
the highest conflict zones well it's not
hard i mean africa clearly
um suffers a lot of regular conflict
it's different i mean if you look at
some latin american cities for example
um brazil or
mexico they're not they wouldn't call it
war they're not at war
but the fights between gangs involve an
awful lot of
young people lots of young people at
times getting killed
they are pretty well armed at times
um so it varies with the sort of
conflicts
that you see in the middle east um
clearly there's been some tremendous
upheavals
um syrian civil war
with people just stopped counting in
terms of the loss of life there because
it became impossible to follow
what was going on but certainly hundreds
of thousands of people have died
and as a professor of ward you still
think that the
the word war has meaning is it
significant
as you said like they're not at war but
will we ever reach a point where
one nation declares war on another
well i mean yeah i mean countries can go
to war
um i mean the origins of the notion of
war
are constantly the word war uh
comes from an old word meaning sort of
confusion
um and so disorderly time
and obviously mayhem and violence and so
on
and that doesn't have to be state on
state
um and so
you know there's always there is always
a question the example i was given
before about militias fighting in a
in in a city is that war is it gang
violence
at what point can you call it a civil
war
is that a useful concept or should we
just keep it to
interstate wars um the fact is it's used
in the way it's used it's not it's one
of those words that's
got out of its box a long time ago so
anytime
organized groups are fighting each other
it'll be called a war sometimes we talk
about
you know cyber war where nobody's
getting killed or as much violence
um just we're referring to conflict i
think
that actually starts not to be helpful i
think
to me war involves purposes of violence
if
people are using violence for a purpose
then it's probably justifiable to call
it war
if they're just in conflict it's not
politically helpful
and what about the role of uh war
studies in general
and a lot of focus in politics and in
academia is on
war rather than peace is there an extent
to which
a focus on war perpetuates the sort of
uh
presence of war well used to be a sort
of slogan of my department if you
if you want peace think about war um
there is actually department of peace
studies um
actually in the war studies department
at kings um
there's an awful lot of work would be
could well come under the heading of
peace studies
conflict resolution uh conflict
avoidance um
i mean sort of a myth about a war
studies that
sort of is militarist and promotes war
so to say we've got quite a backlog to
study we don't need any more
so uh it's a phenomenon
it exists it happens and
you can learn a lot about societies uh
human beings in terms of how wars are
fought
hopefully you can also learn what you
need to do
to stop it or to bring it to a close
quickly sometimes sometimes to find it
more efficiently if that's what you have
to do
so i think there's a point in study it
wouldn't do for everybody to do it
there's nicer things to study it's it's
it's it's
a way to spend one's life but uh uh and
probably just as well some people do it
and are there any leaders at the moment
that you think are particularly
signs of hope in the way that they go
about their foreign policy or
it's not a good time not really
i mean i think there are there are some
there are some sensible people around in
europe and elsewhere
um but if you look at the heads of the
major powers of
russia china and the united states they
think they're all flawed
in different ways and uh
it's a good test as to
whether or not uh the
rational considerations about the
dangers of war
um keep us out of conflict when you have
leaders who can be quite
bellicose finally are there any uh
thinkers books
war strategists that you have
particularly inspired you and you would
recommend to others
um well
i think there's there's a lot of good
writing historical writing about war i
think
probably this this period has produced
this last 10 years has produced some of
the best military histories
about the second world war and so on
because
i think what's happened is that
there's been a greater readiness to look
at
the experience of war of individuals so
that you marry
um war as lived experience for those on
the battlefield or those in the home
front or wherever
so i i think that there's a
a lot to be said for books which now
look at
war as lived experience whether in
battle
you know on the home front as against
just
but you need this as well what were the
strategies being followed by the by the
powers what led them into war why did
they do it the way they did it
um you need that as well so i think the
the good military history
uh marries that and you know it
this country anthony b the max hastings
uh james holland i mean there and then
many others are good
with this sort of military strategy
interestingly people still go back to
classics
clouds of its on war uh
produced uh early 1830s
posthumously by his wife it's still a
remarkable
book in a powerful book about the
different
the interaction interplay of
politics military capability popular
will
battlefield conditions it's a very
powerful piece of work in recent times
the economist tom schelling
who was largely
trying to engage with nuclear issues
genuinely innovative thinker
in helping us understand the extent to
which even
people that conflict with each other
sometimes have shared interests and that
can shape the way
that they fight so that they don't fight
to the death they understand
that that's not what they want to do so
they try to find ways
of bargaining uh that don't involve
complete catastrophe and finally if you
had the chance to
set the curriculum of histories in
schools in this country
over the last 100 years what were the
like the core lessons that you would
want
uh school children or
people to learn about from the wars
we've been involved in
gosh i mean i think you know there's
only so much war you can cram down
youngster's throat
um and i think one of the difficulties
we tend to get very fixated
on the first world war
um in terms of the experience of the
trenches or
the second world war in terms of the
rise of the nazis and
so on and obviously kids do need to know
about this sort of thing
um the further we get away from it the
more distant
these experiences are
i think there is a real challenge
of trying to get
over why our countries did get
involved in these things but i also
think they need to know some recent
history
you know it's surprising the people
will tell you you know kids will tell me
a lot
about the third reich um
but they don't know very much about the
cold war or the cuban missile crisis or
berlin
uh and probably even less
about what was going on in the 90s
and you know these are
um as far away from them as
the first world war say was for me when
i was a kid so i i think
um they need to know
some more contemporary stuff uh as
you know at some point at some point the
remembrance of the first and second
world wars
while always being important shouldn't
crowd out
um helping them try to understand why we
are where we are at the moment
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv